music is a language
both music and verbal languages serve
the same purpose
they are both forms of expression they
can be used as a way to communicate with
others they can be read and written they
can make you laugh or cry think or
question and can speak to one or many
and both can definitely make you move
in some instances music works better
than the spoken word because it doesn't
have to be understood to be effective
although many musicians agree that music
is a language it is rarely treated as
such many of us treat it as something
that can only be learned by following a
strict regimen under the tutelage of a
skilled teacher this approach has been
followed for hundreds of years with
proven success but it takes a long time
to long think about the first language
you learned as a child more importantly
think about how you learned it you are a
baby when you first started speaking and
even though you spoke the language
incorrectly you were allowed to make
mistakes and the more mistakes you made
the more your parents smile learning to
speak was not something you were sent
somewhere to do only a few times a week
now the majority of the people you spoke
to or not paying enemies they were
already proficient speakers
imagine your parents forcing you to only
speak to other babies until you were
good enough to speak to them you
probably be an adult before you can
carry on a proper conversation to use a
musical term as a baby you were allowed
to jam with professionals if we approach
music in the same natural way we
approached our first language we will
learn to speak it in the same short time
it took the speed back first and proof
of this can be seen in almost any family
where a child grows up with other
musicians
here are a few keys to follow in
learning or teaching music in the
beginning embrace mistakes instead of
correcting them like a child playing air
guitar there are no wrong notes allow
young musicians to play and perform with
accomplished musicians on a daily basis
encourage young musicians to play more
than they practice the more they play
the more they will practice on their own
music comes from the musician's not the
instrument and most importantly remember
that a language works the best when we
have something interesting to say many
music teachers never find out what their
students have to say we only tell them
what they are supposed to say
a child speaks a language for years
before they even learn the alphabet too
many rules at the onset will actually
slow them down in my eyes the approach
to music should be the same after all
music is a language too
you